BHAVIK SINGH: My
name is Bhavik Singh.
I'm a product manager
on the Awareness API.
MAURICE CHU: And my
name is Maurice Chu.
I'm the [? engineer ?]
for Awareness.
BHAVIK SINGH: And
today, we're going
to be introducing a
new API that makes
it super easy to make
your applications more
context-aware.
But first, I want to
be on the same page
about why we're talking about
this in the first place.
If you think back to the
keynote just a few hours ago,
Sundar talked about how
mobile has taken off
like a rocket ship.
And what this has done is
pretty fundamentally changed
the way that we, as users,
use our mobile phones,
our wearables, and even
our IoT embedded devices.
In the desktop world, I
would open up a computer
and have these long
prologue sessions
with multiple pages of content.
I would input my intention into
the computer with a keyboard
and a highly precise mouse.
But with devices
that are much smaller
and that come with
us everywhere we
go, we now glance
at them in the bus,
quickly, to check the calendar,
while walking to a meeting,
and maybe even to play a game
while bored at an I/O talk,
or something like that.
So we, as developers,
understand these changes.
And we've actually
made a lot of updates
to our applications
to accommodate them.
New user interface patterns have
emerged, like material design,
that are much
lighter and simpler
than their desktop counterparts.
We have new ways of inputting
intention into our devices,
like voice, stickers,
and emoji, that
allow users to
express themselves
without the need of a
large physical keyboard.
But we at Google believe
that we can actually do more.
Today, we're still
treating these phones
like tiny computers.
In fact, they're quite
different from computers,
though, because they're
jam packed with sensors.
And with powerful
algorithms, these sensors
allow our phones to be aware
of the context around them.
And in turn, the phone
can tell the applications
where the user is, what they're
doing, and what's around them.
You can use this
information to build
more assistive and
aware applications that
can help users in
their day to day lives.
So to dive a little
deeper, I want
to give you a few examples of
what a more aware an assistive
world would look like.
We all have a morning routine.
And for me, personally, it
involves waking up to an alarm.
And usually, at this point,
I'm incredibly groggy,
because I slept way
too late last night.
And I'm pissed
off with my phone,
because I don't have
my first meeting
until four hours from now.
So why am I awake?
Your alarm can be more
aware of these signals.
It can understand
when you went to sleep
and when your first
meeting is, to adjust
the time that it wakes you up.
So at this point, I'm having
a pretty decent morning.
And the next big thing for me to
do is to get ready for the day.
So usually, this
involves reaching
for my phone to
check a weather app,
or go to some weather service.
And now I've become distracted
by this swarm of notifications.
I have a Snapchat
I need to look at.
And my day has become
pretty distracted.
What if my phone found a
nearby TV through Chromecast
and projected onto
it the day's weather?
So now, as I walk from
my bed to my closet,
with one easy glance, I
can see the day's weather
and know that I've got
to get a rain jacket.
Finally, at this point,
I'm pretty relaxed.
I'm sitting at my breakfast
table having cereal.
And while I'm doing that,
an assistant application
is looking at driving
and location patterns
across thousands of
users and realizes
that there's a lot of traffic.
So it wakes up a nearby speaker,
maybe my Google home device,
and says, hey,
Bhavik, you should
leave within the
next five minutes
so you're not late for
your first meeting.
This morning-- there is
usually this chaotic storm
of applications, and services,
and questions-- is now
this elegant, easy experience,
just because a few applications
were more aware.
Let's walk through
another example.
We in the Bay Area
here love our parks.
And for me personally, I love
running through Golden Gate
Park.
So very often, on a weekend
morning, I'll wake up,
I'll strap on my
brand new Android
Wear device and head out the
door into the California sun.
Half an hour into the
run, I'm like, oh, shit,
I forgot to actually
start tracking my run.
What if your
wearable was smarter,
and it automatically detected
that you were running
and launched the
fitness app for you?
It could then track
your distance,
your cadence, and
your heart rate,
so that you can automatically
keep track of those fitness
goals and finally achieve
those New Year's resolutions.
Now, music is a
big part of my run.
What if, as soon as I
plugged in my headphones,
I got a notification
from my favorite music
application saying, here is
the best sunny running playlist
for today?
With one tap, I can
listen to the right music
to keep my feet moving.
Finally, if you
guys know me at all,
you'll figure out that I get
distracted very, very easily.
So while I'm on my run, I
just see this cute little dog.
I've got to take a photo.
So I reach for my phone,
and the launcher application
knows that Bhavik often takes
photos when he's outside.
So it puts the camera app right
in the center of my screen.
And when I take this
photo, it tags it
with not only the
location, but also
the weather and the activity.
So later on, I can
search for photos
that I took while running.
It can find that tag and
quickly show me this dog again.
I'm happy now.
Finally, I want to talk
through one more example.
Driving is really, really
difficult to multitask.
What if we lived in a world
where aware applications made
it easier?
So as soon as I got into
the car and started driving,
my Bluetooth turned on and
connected to the car speakers.
My favorite navigation
app opened up
and launched into driving mode.
Now, the user performs
one very simple action,
which is starting to drive, and
his entire situation, scenario,
and applications are set up
perfect for that journey.
As he's along his way, I get
a notification on my phone
that says, hey, you're
actually near a pharmacy,
and you need to
pick up medications.
Be sure to do this, because the
store's actually still open,
and you're going to drive by it.
These sorts of aware experiences
can really help your users,
but also help you,
as developers.
Tasks like launching
the Maps application
while the user's driving,
or setting an alarm,
are tasks that users
perform every single day.
They're highly
critical for them.
And if your
applications are aware,
you can streamline
these critical tasks.
In turn, your app becomes a
part of their habits, which
can increase your retention.
Suggesting the right
playlist when you're running,
or reminding a user
to buy medication,
is suggesting important
actions to your users, ones
that they might
even have forgotten.
And these sorts of
actions will mean
that they're more likely to
click on your notifications,
if those actions are
tailored, which can increase
your click-through rate on the
very, very important actions
that you care about.
Finally, when you tag a
photo with weather and make
it searchable later, or you
show me the rest of my day
on a nearby TV, that's a moment
of delight for me as a user.
It's something that makes
me want to rate your app 5
stars in the store, or
tell my friends about it.
And these sort of
moments of delight
can drive more users
to your application.
So whether you're a music
streaming service, a health
and fitness tracker, a local
recommendation app, an alarm
or driving app, or really any
other sort of application,
you can use the power of aware
experiences to help your users,
but also hit your
goals as developers.
Now, at this point in the talk,
you guys must be thinking, wow,
this is all really cool.
I want to add it to my
roadmap, but this stuff
is really difficult to build.
That's where we come in.
We, as a team, build Android
awareness and location APIs.
And what we do is we bridge
the physical world where
your users live, work, and play,
and the digital world where
your applications
and Android are.
We focus on this so
that you can focus
on building more aware and
assistive context applications.
To dive deeper, we
think about the signals
that we provide in
three main buckets.
The first one is where
you are, or location.
Location is pretty fundamental
to the human experience, second
only maybe to time.
And so we fulfill this
need with three APIs.
The first one is called
Fused Location Provider,
and it provides highly
accurate latitude and longitude
information by combining signals
across a variety of sensors.
On top of Fused Location,
we have a geo-fencing API
that lets you specify a latitude
and longitude and a radius,
which is called a fence.
When a user walks
into that fence,
your app can wake up and
suggest or perform an action.
If you want to learn
more about these APIs,
visit our talk at 6:00 PM today
called Making Android Sensors
and Location Work For You.
Don't worry if you
didn't catch that.
There's a link at the end with
all the talks that I mention.
On top of lat/long, we also
have semantic location.
What semantic location
means is I never
say I'm at this
latitude or longitude,
I say, hey, I'm at the
Starbucks, or the coffee shop.
And maybe your app wants to
get photos of a Starbucks
or get the open
hours of some place.
If you're interested in
that type of information,
you should check
out the Places API
and learn more in
our talk tomorrow,
Understand Your
Place in the World.
We're very happy that
a lot of developers
enjoy using our location APIs.
And many of you
in the crowd today
might have also been using
them in your own applications.
Within Google, Google Maps
is the obvious example.
It uses not only Fused
Location Provider, but also
the Places API to help people
find their place in the world
and navigate it.
The second big bucket of
signals that we think about
is what you're doing.
Our phones today have
these tiny physical sensors
that tell the phone where it
is with respect to gravity, how
fast it's moving, what
its orientation is
in the real world.
And we build a layer
of intelligence
on top of these
sensors to provide you,
as a developer,
semantic information
about what the user is doing.
The first API for this is
called Activity Recognition,
and it can tell you if a
user is running, walking,
biking, driving.
And we're excited to introduce
new types, like push ups,
sit ups, and squats, this year.
On top of Activity
Recognition, we
have a very powerful
fitness platform
that allows applications to
read and write fitness data.
So if you're interested
in data like nutrition,
or how much a person has
run, or what their weight is,
be sure to go to our
talk tomorrow which talks
about Android Wear and fitness.
Finally, underlying
all these APIs
is our core Android
Sensors platform.
And it gives you
access to this raw data
that lets you build
powerful games, and activity
recognition, and
fitness experiences.
If you want to learn more
about the Sensors API,
visit our talk later today at
6:00 PM, Making Android Sensors
and Location Work For You.
Now, a lot of applications,
thousands of them,
are using activity recognition.
But one of my favorites
is Google Fit.
It detects how much I've
walked, run, or biked every day,
and combines that with
more advanced information
so that I can keep track of my
fitness goals and get in shape.
Finally, the last bucket of
signals that we think about
is something that's up and
coming and incredibly exciting.
And it's called,
"what's around you."
In today's world, we have
more and more devices,
phones, beacons, TVs, and they
all need to talk to each other.
The nearby suite of APIs helps
you, as a developer, do this.
Its Messages API allows you to
send messages between devices.
And its Connections
API allows you
to maintain persistent
connections between devices,
which is useful for things
like multiplayer gaming.
That team is also very
excited to announce a new API
later today at
their talk, Nearby,
Proximity Within
and Without Apps.
So be sure to check that out.
Chromecast is one of my
favorite applications
that uses the Nearby
API, and they use it
to power this amazing
feature called guest mode.
Guest mode means, when
you come to my house,
you can actually use my
Chromecast device, even
if you're not on the
same Wi-Fi network,
just because you're
physically close to it.
That's awesome.
So that's it, really.
We have nine APIs that
tell you where you are,
what you're doing,
and what's around you.
Now, in building these APIs
and building the products that
use them, we've learned
a lot about what
signals are important for people
and where problems can arise.
And so Maurice is going
to talk a little bit
about those problems and some
solutions we have for you.
MAURICE CHU: Great.
Thanks, Bhavik.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So we have nine APIs.
These help you sense,
basically, where the user is,
what they're doing,
and what's around them.
And in my opinion, the
real power of these signals
is not what you can do
with them individually,
but when you combine
them together.
And that way, you can
get a holistic view
about what the user's
context really is.
Now, we actually went back and
tried to put these together,
and we did run into some issues.
And what we saw is
that these APIs really
look something more like this.
They're individual
puzzle pieces that
don't quite fit well together.
So let me explain exactly
what I mean by how they're not
quite fitting together well.
All right.
So let's go back to the example
of getting a reminder when
you're driving near a store.
Now, to implement this, we
have basically a geo-fence API.
And that allows you to set
a region around the store
to detect that the
user is in there.
And then we also have the
activity recognition API
that can detect whether the
user is actually in a vehicle
or not.
Now, it's easy enough to just
invoke both of these APIs,
call into it, get
your callbacks,
and then try to combine
those signals together.
Now, at this point,
we haven't given you
any tools or utilities
to actually put
these signals together, so
you're kind of on your own.
Now you say, OK, that's not
too big of a deal, right?
Just have a couple of
callbacks, put them together.
No big deal.
But the big issue here
actually is system health.
And what do I mean
by system health?
So system health is everything
about how well the phone is
functioning, right?
And the two major factors
for mobile devices
is the battery and the RAM.
Now, battery is kind
of obvious, right?
If you start using too much of
the battery, then it'll drain.
And at that point, you have
a phone that doesn't work,
which is not good for the user.
And the second one is a
little bit more subtle.
In terms of RAM usage, if
there's too many things
running on the device, this
can cause some CPU thrashing.
And the issue with that
is that, then, the phone
starts to get sluggish.
And that also leads to a
pretty poor user experience.
OK, so why should
you care about this?
Now, the thing is,
if the user suspects
that it's your app
causing the battery drain,
or it's your app causing that
phone to become sluggish,
they may actually, in the
worst case, uninstall your app.
And actually, that's probably
the worst case scenario here.
And the irony of
the situation is
that you've been trying
your best to actually target
that very specific
situation when the user is
driving near the
store, and hence
make it very relevant to them.
But if you don't do
that right, then you
may end up actually causing
a worse user experience.
All right.
So let me dig a little bit
deeper about system health.
So in this case, like I
said, probably the first way
you could implement
this is to call
into the geo-fence API and
the activity recognition API,
get the callbacks, and
combine them together.
Sure, no problem.
But now that you have two
signals you're hooking into,
you actually have
some other options
to do things a little bit
in a more optimized way.
So another way to
do it is, instead,
just turn on the geo-fence
API first, make sure
that the user actually
is near the store.
And in that case, and
only in that case,
do you turn on the
activity recognition
to determine that the
user is in the vehicle.
And of course, there's
an alternative.
You can do the
opposite direction.
Instead, call into the
activity recognition API first.
And then, when you detect
that the user is driving,
then call into
the geo-fence API.
Now, the big question is, which
is the best for system health?
You know, which is
the one that's going
to drain the battery the least?
Which one's going to cause the
least amount of CPU thrashing?
All right.
So it's actually
a trick question.
There's actually
many, many factors
that really go into
determining which
is going to be better than the
other, things like the sampling
rate that you choose
for each of these.
And then there's also lots
of implementation details
that you may not
be aware of, things
like how many times
the radio wakes up,
and how much time
the CPU is using.
And there's also,
all the way down
to the hardware, how much power
that the sensor is drawing.
All right.
So anyways, if you have
two, you may say, OK,
that's not too bad.
And you can do some work to
tune it, and then make sure
that system health is good.
But really, the power is again
combining all these signals.
So imagine scaling
up to all of these.
Now, at this point,
you're actually
facing a pretty tough problem.
There's a lot more
code to handle.
And if you're really going to
try to optimize system health,
I mean, now you're talking
exponentially more different
combinations you have
to consider in order
to do this well.
The other issue is that the
more APIs that you hook into,
that means the more your
app will actually wake up.
And this actually causes some
pretty bad memory pressure.
And in the end, it
could actually end up
causing a sluggish phone.
And again, we don't
really want that.
So the issues today,
again, are in order for you
to hook into these APIs, you do
have to learn multiple of them
for each type of context signal.
And the issue is that
there are subtleties you
have to learn about, things like
how do you choose a sampling
rate?
And there are things
called like priority level.
And these are pretty
subtle things to figure out
how to use properly.
The other thing is,
now, there's no support
for combining these
signals together.
So you have to write
that code to do that.
And then, furthermore, even
after you've done all that,
you may end up with battery
drain and sluggishness that can
be pretty difficult to solve.
So our challenge
was to figure out,
can we make these individual
puzzle pieces fit together
into a whole puzzle?
And our goals
here, we'll say, is
it possible to arrange
our APIs so that we
can make it very
easy to combine them
together, and so that
you can really target
those specific situations?
At the same time, these
issues with system health,
is there something
that we can do
to help you guys all do that?
Well, I'm very excited
today to announce
that we have a solution
for this problem,
and we call it
the Awareness API.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
All right.
So the Awareness API, it's
a unified sensing platform
enabling apps to be aware of
all aspects of a user's context,
while managing the
system health for you.
We've designed this
so that you can
engage your users in very
targeted, very specific,
contextual conditions.
Now, it'll be available
shortly after I/O
as a Google Play services API.
Now, for now, let me
give you a preview
about what we have to offer.
So for our first
release, we'll be
offering seven different
context types right off the bat.
So this will help
you answer questions,
like where is the user,
via the lat/long locations,
as well as the semantic
notions of locations
that we call Places.
Also, what's around you?
Things like can we detect nearby
beacons around you, just so you
have an idea of what's there.
We also have some code to
help you basically combine,
tie in, with some of these
other conditions as well.
And also, to answer
questions like,
what is the user doing
via the Activities?
And we also found that there's
some interesting device
states, things like whether
the headphones are plugged in,
which have some notion about how
the user is using that device.
And finally, things
like ambient conditions
in the environment, things
like weather, which actually do
have an effect on
user's behavior,
like today, being extremely
hot and muggy outside.
All right.
So now, the biggest
challenge that we had to face
was, how do we simplify these
nine APIs into something that's
much easier to use,
and also allows
you to combine the
signals together?
And the way we approached this
problem is to consider, well,
why don't we think
about the common usage
patterns of how app developers
want to use these APIs?
Right?
What are the ways you want
to actually use and access
these context signals?
And we came up with
two of them that covers
a good, broad range of these.
So the first one is
called the Fence API.
And this is a
callback style API.
The idea is that you
register a listener
with a specific set of
conditions that you want,
and then that gets called back.
And then you can
react accordingly.
Now, the word "fence" may
seem a little bit mysterious,
but it comes from geo-fencing
where the idea there
was to set up a
geo-fence, and then
the software would then detect
whether the user is in there.
Now, we realize this is actually
a generalizable concept.
We don't have to be doing
just fences in location,
but also fences in all
types of user state,
things like is the
user walking or not,
are the headphones
plugged in, and is it
hot and sunny outside.
So all of these we
can consider a fence.
And that's what the
Fence API gives you.
All right.
So let me give you a
concrete example of how
we can use this Fence API to
accomplish one of the scenarios
that we talked about earlier.
Now, this one had
two parts to it.
The first was the
user gets in the car.
And then, now your
device goes, amazingly,
into this in-car mode.
And the second half of it
was, as you're driving nearby
the pharmacy, you actually get a
reminder to pick up medication.
All right.
So with the Fence API,
the first thing to do
is determine the condition
that you want to detect.
So that first one was to
detect whether the user has
started driving.
Now in this case,
it's very easy.
We have built in a subset
of primitive fences
based on the context types.
And we have the
detected activity fence.
And you just merely
specify, OK, I
want to know when the user is
starting to be in a vehicle.
And this condition is true when
you first get into the vehicle.
Simple.
OK.
Now, the other condition
is a little bit more
involved, if I want to
be driving near the store
while it's open.
So in this case, we'll
start off at the bottom.
The things you need are,
first, a kind of a geo-fence
or a location fence
around the store.
This is what that first line is.
Now, the second line
shows a condition
to basically detect when
the user is actually
in the vehicle itself.
And that's what that
DetectedActivityfence is.
And the last one is
we probably don't
want to show notifications
when the store is not open.
So what we can do
instead is create
a time fence that is only
true between those open hours.
In this case, we show
it in the example
between 10:00 AM and 6:00 PM.
Now, one thing to think
about, what is a fence here?
Well, it's actually
a Boolean condition.
And it takes a value
of true or false.
And actually, that
gives us our key
to how to combine these things.
Once you have
Boolean conditions,
you can combine them with the
Boolean operators of AND, OR,
and NOT.
So in this point, for
this specific example,
let's actually do that.
So we want to combine these.
And the AND operator is
what's appropriate here.
So now, we have
our full condition,
which is true when the user is
in the area around the store,
the user is driving,
and it's open hours.
OK.
So now you have your two fences.
And we need to
basically register
this with the Awareness API.
So you create your fence update
request, add your fences,
and then just call updateFences.
And voila.
Your fences are registered.
A couple of things to note.
We do understand
that, probably, you
want to key off of multiple
conditions of the user.
So our API is situated
so you can actually
add multiple fences.
And in doing so, you need
to also give us a key.
That's what that first
string, startDriving,
and drivingNearStore
are, so that you
can know which of the fences are
actually calling back to you.
The other thing to note is that
the pending intents can all go
to the same callback mechanism.
That will help
simplify your code
to handle all the callbacks.
And the last point is that
you pass in a pending intent.
And the nice thing there is
that your app doesn't even
have to be running.
We'll be computing
these conditions for you
and give you the callback
at the right time.
And this is how we're
helping with system health.
Your app can stay completely
out of the way of the system.
And yet, you can react when
these conditions happen.
[APPLAUSE]
Ah.
Thank You.
OK.
So now, let's finish this off.
Let's write the callback.
In this case, we show receiving
the callbacks via a broadcast
receiver.
You get your data
through the intent.
We have a utility function to
extract that state into what
we call a fence state.
And now, for the
first condition,
if you know that the
key that you have passed
in-- in this case,
startDriving--
is true, then based on the
condition of the state,
you can show the Maps
app in the in-car mode.
And for the second
one, you can also key
off of that one, which
is drivingNearStore,
check the state of the fence,
and then show the reminder.
So this is our Fence
API, and it allows
you to react when the user is
in very specific contextual
conditions that you specify.
All right.
So let's talk about
the Snapshot API now.
This is polling style API.
And the idea is that your
app, while it's running,
can just ask what the current
values of these different types
of contexts are, things like
the location, the activity,
the weather, et cetera.
So let's go back
to the scenario.
So at this point, Bhavik
saw this cute little dog.
So he wanted to snap
a picture of that.
And on top of that,
what he wanted to do
was tag it with the
current semantic location
and the weather.
OK, and this is really easy.
Really, we have an API,
called the Snapshot API.
You just call two
methods, one to get
the places, others to get the
weather, pull out the data.
Then you can tag
it to your photo
and share it with the world.
One thing we did
do is that we added
caching underneath to
basically not allow
you to have to think too
much about what kind of cost
there is to call
into these APIs.
OK, so to summarize,
the Awareness API
will be releasing with
seven different context
types and two simple APIs.
Now, we've designed this
so that, in the future,
we can add more context
types, and yet not increase
the complexity it takes for you
to incorporate the new signals
as we go forward.
And then, of course,
the other part of it
is that we try to handle
system health for you,
so that you don't have
to worry about it.
And by simplifying
this for you, you
can focus your efforts on
building that great experience
for your users.
All right.
So let me take a step
back and talk a little bit
about where I feel the Awareness
API fits in the grander scheme
of things.
Personally, when
I first got a hold
of a smartphone, the thing that
really amazed me and really
kind of excited me was the fact
that it had a bunch of sensors.
And just having
sensors was not enough.
It was the fact that people
actually carried these phones
with them everywhere they went.
Now, once you do that, there's
a real opportunity for the phone
to really know who
you are, what you
care about, what your
intentions are, et cetera.
And if the phone can know that
and your apps can know that,
then I think we could
build these kinds
of magical experiences that have
basically never existed before.
And we have a kind of a new
relationship with computing.
So that was kind
of the moon shot.
And that's what
we've been working
towards trying to get to.
Now, the Awareness API is kind
of a step in that direction.
And what we've done with
that is to basically take
these separate, individual
sensing capabilities,
put them all together
into a unified platform.
And whether that's a big step
or a small step, time will tell.
But it is a step to simplify
things so that now you
can build better experiences.
Now, this is
incredibly powerful.
And we'll be putting it
soon into your hands.
But really, to reach
this moon shot,
it's not about the technical
capabilities as well.
There's other things
that are of concern.
And one of those things is
privacy, of course, right?
So we must be respectful
of the user's privacy.
And the real challenge here is
to build those experiences that
really simplify and delight
the users in ways that they
have never felt before.
And as far as I can tell, in
order to get to that moon shot,
I don't see any path to
success that doesn't include
respecting the user's privacy.
And I'm sure you'll
agree, as well.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah.
All right.
So part of the addressing
privacy is what we can do.
And the Awareness API is built
in with a permission model,
using Android's
permission model.
So for each type of
context, we do protect it
against one of these
Android permissions,
so that we can ensure that
the user has given consent
to your app to actually
access that signal.
Now, most of these
are pretty intuitive.
But things like
weather, for example,
does require
ACCESS_FINE_LOCATION
permissions.
And the reason is
because we're giving you
the weather at the
user's current location.
OK, so that's what we've done.
But of course, addressing
privacy doesn't end there.
It really has to be end-to-end.
And that includes, in your
app, what kind of experience
that you're building.
Now the two basic principles we
follow for addressing privacy
are transparency and control.
And transparency is
about, basically,
letting the user know what
it is that we're using,
what personal information
we're using about them,
as well as what
we're using it for.
And the second half of it
is, of course, control.
We have to let the
users-- give them
the ability to actually activate
or deactivate these features.
So just to give you a
quick example-- I mean,
if I plug in my headphone,
and my favorite music
app automatically
starts playing music,
I mean, that's
fantastic, but only
if it was transparent to me
that that was going to happen,
and I have the option
to actually turn it off
if I don't want it.
OK.
I think one of the
immediate uses of Awareness
will be to post
notifications to the user.
And we do ask that you try to
be as specific and as targeted
as possible.
That way, you'll basically hit
the user at the most relevant
moments, when they actually
want to take action
on that notification
you send them.
One thing to note though,
as an Android [INAUDIBLE],
users can disable
notifications for your app.
And also the notification
shade is a shared resource
across all apps.
So of course, you need
to give them a reason
to turn your notifications on.
And finally, we've done our best
to be as efficient as possible
to address system health.
But please be mindful about what
fences you happen to register.
Make sure that you weigh it
against the user experience
enhancement that
you're providing.
Now again, to conclude, the
Awareness API is coming soon.
And I very much look forward
to seeing what you guys end up
building with it.
Now at this point, let me
turn this over to Bhavik,
and he'll tell us
what our partners have
been up to with this.
[APPLAUSE]
BHAVIK SINGH: Thanks, Maurice.
Cool.
So as Maurice has shown
you, we have a new API
that makes it super easy for
your applications to be aware.
We let this out to the
wild a little early
and let a few
partners play with it.
And I'd love to show you
what they've been able to do.
Trulia is an online
real estate agent.
And one of the big
parts of their service
is helping their users
and potential home buyers
find and visit open houses.
Something they've
struggled with in the past
is, when should I send
these users a notification
to remind them to
visit an open house?
Sure, I could do it when
they're near the area where
the house is, but what if
they're driving through it,
or it's a rainy day, and
they're just not feeling it?
So with the Awareness
API's Fence feature,
they've actually been able
to create highly tailored
notifications.
You will only get a
notification for an open house
if you're in the right location,
if the weather is nice,
and you're walking, and
not driving or running
through the area.
They're very excited to see how
this more tailored notification
will increase click-throughs
on this very important action
for them.
One of my favorite photo
editing applications is Aviary.
It's a powerful
editing tool that
lets you take and edit photos
to really capture a moment.
One of the big
features they have
is a stream where you can see
photos that other people have
taken, to get some inspiration.
A thing that they realize is
the way that you take and edit
a photo depends a
lot on your context.
The way I capture a
rainy day in Seattle
is going to be very
different from the way
I capture a sunny day
in Yosemite, or maybe
a sweltering day, like
I/O. And so what they've
been able to do with
the Awareness API
is use Snapshot to understand
what your place is,
what your semantic location
is, and the weather,
to show you photos that could
inspire you to capture and edit
that perfect moment.
Finally, music is really
near and dear to my heart.
And Superplayer Music is a
music streaming application
that is very popular
in Latin America.
They have this
amazing assistant bot
feature where you can ask
it for recommendations,
and it will return
recommendations to you.
What they've been able to do
with Awareness and plan to do
is merge those functionalities
with context signals.
So that now, when I've
just finished running
and I'm looking for something
to cool down while stretching,
when I get to the
gym, or maybe when
I'm about to go
on a long journey,
they can suggest the right
music for the moment.
Those are not the only
partners that we work with.
And we're very
lucky to have been
involved with a wide
variety of applications.
In the health and
fitness space, Runkeeper
is thinking about tagging its
running posts with weather.
We have local applications,
like Trulia and Zillow,
that help people find
the things that they need
and the homes that they
want while around them.
Grubhub is also thinking about
how they can integrate weather
with their features,
and so is Kekanto.
We've got photo
editing applications,
like I showed you with Aviary,
but also Picsart, and even
OS level functionality,
like Nova Launcher, which
is thinking about completely
rewriting its launcher
to be more context-aware
and show you
the right apps at
the right time,
or Zedge, which
is going to allow
for customizations of
ringtones and wallpapers,
based on context.
With these partners, we're
just getting started.
We have nine APIs across where
you are, what you're doing,
and what's around
you, and a brand new
API that we're launching today,
called the Awareness API,
that merges all of this
information in a battery
and system health-friendly way.
I'm very, very excited
to see what all of you
are going to do with it.
If you're interested, sign up
for our preview so that we can
remind you when the API comes
out and get you off of the list
to get an early look at
developers.google.com/awareness.
If you're interested in diving
deeper into any of the other
APIs I talked about today,
visit g.co/AwarenessIO,
to see a full list of our
other talks and open hours.
Thanks.
Me and Maurice will be around,
just outside, for questions
after.
[MUSIC PLAYING]